to BCS code is to be wrecked to be
wronged to be utterly destroyed through
no fault of your own by the one they
call valve
[Music]
now the traditional definition of
getting CS go to involves putting a
crosshair over somebody's head pulling
the trigger and having the bullets go
through them like nothing happened but
for the purposes of this video we've
expanded the definition to include those
pesky bugs those glitches and the
general what the three that has happened
in pro play so let's get it started
with the traditional definition of
getting CS code trying to find a way
over here pronax has managed to spot it
and why how is that not a kill you look
dead on there I love meta change this is
also a second new meta just missing the
easy well is that is not a miss that is
that how is that a miss spot two players
everyone a position oh no there's that
first bullet accuracy presence on a and
so instead you could and it is not gonna
be enough now snacks just gonna be
walking out 9 to 0 in favor of and
sk-gaming my god this is incredible they
are so well prepared for this match SK
it really does feel like they're reading
it like a book what it's Ulta injury
[Music]
devices sees the answer Jacob can
actually learn the shopper know what the
model
he misses out there and Jacob seems like
he's just got CS code Jacob will go for
the repeat throwing device still landing
that shot how did that miss how did that
shut this it's gonna be able to double
down he finds three on the round but how
did that shot for maikelele miss now
while getting CS code can really make
your blood boil arguably worse are the
random seemingly unpredictable bugs that
can cost you your life the round and
even the game minor damage on - lugia
caught a shin bone maybe
[Music]
so in spite of it being expensive SK can
still look forward to a bit of a relaxed
round here did he did Molotov himself he
Molotov the floor no but it looked like
the Molotov went down below how did that
happen there is a bit of a mystery there
we go chaos zeroes in on Cole's Ian who
blima
King engine and the s Monson Xena by
Yahoo Oscars it see own father - Rudolf
see daddy loitering Shingen adulting
let's go zine some sugah via Mickey
Chris Dutchman off I'm adding too much
more aggressive set up a face those mana
stops raining in though gonna make life
hard for AC and he can actually cancel
it out with a smoke either and it's
gonna be a fast bit control sloping
throne I should have smoked mess
JDM is so angry right now their minds
easy better than last time the utility
usage is great here
watch I know he gets done by the Molotov
bug that's so unfortunate the smoke
bounces through rather than putting it
out like it should either way renegades
is doing great work here all the stupid
stuff but valve come on
and we'll transplant them out with the
AWP pop flash coming out the balls off a
push freeze away to smoke that she'll
and oh my god
this smoke bug really hurts the trick
side 25 seconds now salvaged in the
previous round student Amanda will be
producing other looks things
all the bug CS goes and its finest yep
we call that a bug bug it's a feature
now sometimes if it's um out sometimes
it doesn't
yeah it depends on the degree and five
wishes for next nuts that happened so
much now you write that initial trade
for scream just really good job on him
yeah
he held mast one he knew what was coming
out of what is that a graphics bug just
go for the floor actually you can shoot
right through that floor I don't know I
mean who will know that but that whole
box that shocked us in is penetrable
from almost all angles so better to be
safe than sorry walk six little missus
shopper so well I think it's stuck oh no
so favoring the T side there but
considering VG don't have a spook good
weaponry actually ain't caused a bit
damaged on savage so much information
here and they have no idea they can't
even see him it's ridiculous game so
broken it's unbelievable so it's just
able to jump and swap players without
anything being how bow like seriously
vowels how is this function in your game
it's so stupid now around this one out
guys we wanted to look at some of the
more lighthearted glitches in the game
of csgo this kind of stuff you can't
even be mad at just got to sit back and
laugh wait a second what stopped them
they're the bombs are cheap drug is both
underground
I have not seen that before I'm not
gonna lie I have never seen that before
it would appear the Bombers somehow
dropped through the wall below them up
and so I'm looking at Sanders
perspective right now there is no way
they can salvage that bombs they're
gonna have to go to kill
bomb yet to be picked up it has not
crossed to the side what is going on oh
there's no way there is no way there is
no way that has happened bow for God's
sake
time so done there's no no way that that
still happens yes I agree
gave coldzera does it get any bonus
money yes to CC but he's got no monies
that $0 Phelps aggressive behind this
wall with the p2 50s while he open
things up in the last round for SK
gaming
[Music]
that's okay
smoke outside other standard wall glitch
extinguish inside of the door fallen
comrade is it because they're looking
bug and may expecting shots or something
it's like i don't know i shouldn't i
don't even that is the most unique bug I
have seen on KITV and recent memory that
is really it's so well we'll see if
shocks can save this gun and his Kevlar
and it is 5/7 that I didn't even know
what to say
it's like Lucky's got a dull friend who
is just kind of dragging around a bit on
the you know the streets of cobblestone
it can hurdle of Ament of i'ma dxv daddy
Bowser
okay
[Music]
all of us
[Music]
ah
I'm I a loose hammer bunny
so first be Dada
what's the Lowe's paper
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
well guys that's all we got for you this
week on best of now this particular
installment is really near and dear to
my heart because I'm always getting CS
code in my games nobody in the office
even believes me but you guys do right
let me know in the comments and I will
see you next week thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]